Kevin what's the best way to handle
release forms for your documentary film
and then how important is it to actually
have those release forms well it's it's
critical to have the release forms
you're not going to have a film without
the release forms you won't get your Eno
insurance without the release forms you
won't get a release you won't get a
distributor who won't get anything
without him so you have to have them now
there's certain parameters about group
shots and events and rallies where you
don't have to have crowds signing
release forms but your principle
sit-down interviews you have to get
release forms and I have been meticulous
throughout my career of getting release
forms and generally you want to get them
signed before you roll the interview and
then the one time I did not was the
lesson that you know learned and that
was the case where I was interviewing
someone who had experienced a great loss
and it took a long time to get them to
the point where they said yes to do the
interview and so was a very much of a
kind of a evolving relationship of trust
to get to the point where they would sit
down in front of the camera and allow
and allow us into their life and I never
really I always knew I should get that
thing signed but it was always I didn't
want to break this kind of this mood we
were getting in that we could trust each
other and we did the interviews and we
did the story and it turned out to be
much bigger than we ever thought and I
finally went back because I established
such a close relationship with this
person that we're posting the film I had
all the other releases signed in the
normal fashion I do but I had not gotten
this one done yet and I went back to get
the interview and this person said no
they were not going to sign the release
and this story was so central to my film
that without it the film would have
crumbled in that section and so they
said no I will not sign the next thing I
know I get a phone call from an attorney
saying they want a certain amount of
money which is a considerable amount of
money and which we had to pay and to get
the release and but it makes the film
but the point is always get that release
signed and you know you is that it's not
a question of yes or no you have to have
a release you're not going to get you
know distributed without a release form
so emails would not be binding in terms
of someone agreeing to it's not even
think of verbal on-camera releases were
truly binding they could late
they could say I really didn't
understand what I was saying yes to do
you have it on paper and they sign it
they understand that release form so you
have to be very careful about about
release forms you brought up something
interesting crowd shots I did something
the other day on a subway and everybody
was just staring at the camera and I'm
trying to get my subject I had to use
some of that footage what rights does
the public have in terms of what if
someone sees that and says no you didn't
you didn't get a release from me and I
see myself on camera well that's a
little different you know crowd shots
there's a federal size of cratan it's
not the Coliseum or it's not a huge
rally of some form on the mall in
Washington DC that's a crowd shot on a
subway that's you if you're being able
to pick out faces that's a different
dilemma now there are there's a lot of
rules in this but you know as long as
you weren't hiding the camera that's one
thing in your favor because they see a
camera that could always turn away so
the camera was present generally
speaking you know you won't if it's
gonna be on any kind of broadcast TV
they're gonna put up a sign saying if
you were filming here you give you a
consent to be on camera because we're so
you know that's not a professional level
on a network if you're on a subway I'd
be very careful about that because you
are special if you're gonna be showing
faces backs of faces and your and your
and your character fine but you know you
can't blame them they're you know
they're down there doing their thing and
you know you're you're going to be
making money off this image probably if
you sell this movie and they're not
consenting they didn't ever never asked
for their consent to be in the shot so
you got to be careful when they eat when
you recognize their face so it's okay
the backs of someone the likeness of
them for far away but yeah exactly as
long as they're not recognizable or if
there's so many and it's a public event
where the news crews are public and your
cameras in the open that's a different
thing you could it's a new more of a
news context
you